nous avons ces dernières décennies sous
investis en éducation formation
enseignement supérieur et recherche on a
beaucoup d investi quand on se compare
nous sommes un pays qui travaille moins
que les autres en quantité ça reste vrai
et donc nous avons une quantité de
travail à louer qui n'est pas au bon
niveau à la fois dans le cycle de vie en
horaire cumulée et au fond on a une
force qui est notre modèle social et
éducatif on a une faiblesse c'est qu'on
n'a plus le modèle productif qui permet
de le financer il nous faut avoir un
pays qui produisent davantage
alors merci il règne conductrice a raqué
pt qui est venu me voir il règne un
ouais ouais tu as bien le vois bien bien
j'aime bien inventer l'eau c'est
toujours sympathique et c est là l i20
il règne je vous dis tout de suite voilà
les mots de brégeon porte parole la
république en marche conseillère
municipale à levallois ce fait longtemps
vous n'étiez pas venu cela fait
longtemps que tu vas pas en reste et
c'est bon
rien à voir avec la beauté
vous le dis vous allez terminer aux
toilettes aller chercher cette petite
phrase donc n'est pas passée inaperçue
est-ce que vous dachau qu'est la phrase
d'emmanuel maquereau ou est ce que l a
été sorti du contexte ou et benjamin
castelreng nom s'est passé c'est pas
c'est pas choquant d'autant qu'il a
expliqué clairement pourquoi d'autant
qu'on est le pays le plus productif par
été dans l'europe donc voila c'était un
sentiment et c'est vrai que c'est un peu
l'image malheureusement tu es français
renvoie et maintes fois abordé sa patte
au ici on en est un bel exemple sans que
aux manques mode comprend baumann et ben
saad a fait rire d'un fameux kerry voilà
merci
tu sais la fille est heureuse merci
heureusement nobilis au large vous êtes
choqué alors choqué c'est un bien grand
mot disons que je trouve que la sortie
de emmanuel macron est extrêmement
maladroite parce que je trouve qui
globalisent c'est à dire que oui on peut
dire que les français travaillent moins
que les autres mais quel français est ce
qu'un agriculteur qui travaillent 70
heures par semaine et travaille moins
que quelqu'un qui travaille je te faire
dans la fonction publique un ambulancier
que un chauffeur poids lourds que ceux
qui ont été les premiers de cordée
pendant la crise sanitaire donc en fait
je trouve que de globaliser comme ça de
faire des grandes généralités comme ça
je trouve que ça stigmatise et je trouve
que ça voilà je trouve que ça sert à
rien en même temps je trouve que dire ça
alors qu'on est à six mois d'une
élection présidentielle
abbas avait plutôt qu'au juge parce que
justement c'est pas du tout démago et je
trouve que c'est très étonnant voilà
alors irene doit et vénère un mois ça
m'a choqué ouais moi ça m'a choqué ce
cas entendre cette phrase serait 80
minutes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il a été extrêmement choqué
[Rires]
salariés d'abord avec vous alors ouais
donc moi je reviens à la fracture est
que quand je vois qu'ils qui dit qu on
se compare son appui qui serait moins
que les autres ça reste vrai et dissa
devant 200 chefs d'entreprises et des
étudiants plus que sélectionné 200 chefs
d'entreprises j'aurais voulu qu'ils
qu'il est devant lui 200 mamans avec des
mamans aux mères isolées les parents
n'est pas pas et qu'ils sachent que
c'est une journée entre gérer des
enfants et gérer son travail parce que
c'est clair que ce serait du matin à
6h30 pour déposer des enfants ensuite
devoir est gérée du matin au soir le
sport le dîner courir les des fois on
est rappelé pour dire l'enfant est
malade et cetera et cetera je vois pas
comment si on ne rajoute encore une
heure de plus chaque jour en quoi c'est
bénéfique pour nous et pour tout le
monde toute cette heure va pas nous
faire gagner plus d'argent parce
qu'aujourd'hui on va pas se mentir le 1
1 smic horaire un taux horaire est à 8
euros 11 pour gagner 30 euros de plus
par semaine alors que derrière je devoir
payer plus de centres payer plus de
frais de garde payer plus de nourrice
moi derrière je je je perde de ce fait
d'être plus souvent à la maison ce côté
loisir de passer du moment avec mes
enfants pour être au travail et ça va
rien me rapporte en plus donc quand on
parle de productivité tous et moi
aujourd'hui moi ce que je pense c'est ma
famille comment je vais courir comment
je vais gérer de voir le travail on met
trois quarts d'heure à une heure dans
les métros pour rejoindre no no no no
taf autant le matin que le soir en fait
je vois pas comment il peut dire ça mais
c'est normal que 6 2 ils se retrouvent
avec 200 p dg devant lui oui j'aurais
aimé qu'ils se retrouvent devant 200
parents qui travaillent et qui ont une
charge d'enfants dîner maladie rendez
vous médicaux le sport le loisir en fait
il faudrait que je retire le sport à mes
enfants cependant je retire des loisirs
les enfants par exemple concevable et ça
nous met très en colère et j'ai un
groupe de mamans sur loix de sap
justement depuis qu'il est cette phrase
à elles sont choquées toutes les mamans
sont choqués je parle aussi de papa je
crois pas que de maman parce qu'ils ont
aussi des papas que ceux qui sont là
aussi c'est choquant c'est des heures en
plus pour pas grand chose pour nous mode
alors déjà moi ce que je peux dire c'est
qu'il s'agissait pas de stigmatiser
untel ou untel aujourd'hui qu'on regarde
les chiffres on voit que par exemple sur
une année entière c'est vrai que mon
boss - en france que dans d'autres pays
en europe c'est une première chose et
pourquoi il dit ça vers quoi il veut en
venir l'objectif c'est pas par exemple
de revenir sur les 35 heures c'est à
dire bah voilà nous on pense au sein de
la république en marge du gouvernement
que le travail c'est important et qu'on
a envie de valoriser le travail ont
valorisé le travail ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire faire en sorte que le travail
paie mieux c'est par exemple ce qui a
été fait sur l'augmentation de la prime
d'activité sur les heures sup et puis
c'est aussi permettre parce qu'on pense
que le travail va ça apporte certains
salaires mais ça apporte aussi un côté
sociabilisation on rencontre des gens et
puis ça permet de trouver une place dans
la société toit par exemple donc tu
conduis des métros ou 2h pas combien tu
conduis de personnes par jour enfin ce
que tu fais ça a vraiment du sens et ça
a vraiment une utilité sociale et c'est
pour ça qu'on veut faire en sorte que
les gens trouvent du travail et ce qu'on
fait on le fait notamment sur les jeunes
on a par exemple quasiment doubler le
nombre de contrats d'apprentissage et
puis on le fait sur les seniors et les
chômeurs de longue durée aujourd'hui les
gens qui sont inscrits ou pour l'emploi
il n'a plus d'un sur deux qui le sont
depuis plus d'un an et ça veut dire
qu'il ya tout un travail de formation et
donc dans le plan france 2030 il ya 2
milliards qui ont été mis pour permettre
aux gens de se former que ce soit les
jeunes les chômeurs de longue durée et
les seniors aussi aujourd'hui passé sous
55 ans et plus dur de retrouver un
emploi et donc on investit beaucoup là
dessus mais ce n'était pas un message
discriminant le message c'était voilà on
pense que le travail c'est quelque chose
d'important ça donne du sens à la vie et
puis effectivement aujourd'hui il ya un
contrat qui conte travail moins
qu'ailleurs en revanche c'est vrai qu'on
est aussi ici sur le plateau
trouvait alors quand j'entends
entrailles moins qu'ailleurs ça peut
faire une chose c'est du lard c'est bête
à dire mais je voulais pas rentrer dans
les chiffres rouges et partant ce débat
mais c'est la crique news parce que
c'est pas moi qui nomme monsieur mac on
peut dire ça devant n'aimiez pas loger
les chiffres également à travailler
alors la durée moyenne hebdomadaire des
salariés du travail des salariés en
europe regardez
alors 36 voilà donc voilà à 36,8 voilà
donc où est on est on est on est large
au dessus et lui il parlait de ce
qu'était travailler sur une année on est
on est devant on est devant l'allemagne
on n'a plus
passé le plus de temps passé il ya plus
de choses il ya plusieurs catégories
notamment et tout ça n'est pas calculer
mais ça n'est pas pris en compte et
c'est vrai que moi qui ai pas économiste
je me dis tiens on va pas mourir bête on
va regarder les chiffres qui donnent
c'est pas moi qui les donne chez les
chiffres de l eurostat l'office
statistique de l'union européenne les
français ont travaillé en 2020 en
moyenne 37,4 heures donc même plus qui
en matière mentionner ici on est en
moyenne la moyenne en union européenne
37 heures donc on est plus que les
allemands plus que les pays-bas et mais
j'entends sur les meilleurs délais
clairs sur la production en fait non
réalisation il parlait de sur l'année
pourquoi curiae on est moins c'est parce
que vous prenez en compte les actifs et
les inactifs
donc c'est aussi pour ça que ça lisse et
que ça fait moins et on prend également
en compte les rtt et faut faire
en sorte que les moins d'inactifs mais
d'aider les gens à trouver du temps là
les chômeurs et pour les chômeurs disent
être embauchés faut pas trahi plus sinon
rebond doit pas de création en mai ce
qui a été dit c'était pas le président
elle pas dit qu'ils allaient revenir sur
les 35 heures c'est quand tu dis il le
dit devant 200 chefs d'entreprises il le
dit aussi devant amon avis 500 caméras
et donc ils l'assument c'est un message
qui est la succession elle avoir des
applaudissements s'il a des pdg devant
lui et des étudiants il n'a pas
sélectionné d'études
pâlir devant chômeurs des chômeurs alors
vous la phrase d'emmanuel marin moi moi
je me suis sentie insultée vous savez je
respecte les institutions c'est des vols
vote c'est démocratique mais je me suis
sentie insultée parce qu'elle dit
monsieur le président faut qu'il arrête
d'insulter les français qui travaillent
à un moment de leur part qu'ils arrêtent
de nous insulter les premiers de cordée
traverser la rue vous trouverez du
boulot là et nous traitent de saignant
quand c'est pour donner des exemples sur
la suède l'allemagne les pays-bas
regardez ce qu'ils font il roule en vélo
nous aussi vous roule en vélo regard
social d'hidalgo d'un an les mêmes même
les gouvernements même pas que macron
ceux d'avant aussi ils prennent toujours
les exemples sur les autres pays et là
ils nous traitent de fainéants alors que
les autres pays on l'a vu il travaille
pas plus que nous il ya des bouchons
dans toutes les grandes villes à partir
de 6h30 les français ils sont déjà dans
la rue quand on veut les politiques sont
en train de prendre leur petit déjeuner
clan orange pressé avec le chauffeur qui
attend devant la voiture qui fait
tourner la bagnole et là on parle pas de
position ce que ces messieurs alors
qu'ils aient le chauffage quand le
voyais quand le chauffeur ils attendent
dans la maison c'est pas bien de dire ça
il parle d'un pot l'impôt sur la société
déjà commencer déjà par baisser l'impôt
sur les sociétés on est avec les sens et
les impôts sur la société c'est ce qu'il
ya plus c'est ce qu'il ya de plus -
quand ils traitent de feignants comme ça
moi j'ai pas envie il a parlé de vous
mais non mais il a dit que je
travaillais pas mais nous on n'a pas
demandé leur hymne 5h with il a dit les
français
mais
qu'est ce que vous faites vous vous
dormez à l'assemblée il ya six ans
députée depuis 129 députés vous donnez à
l'assemblée je me mets la fois
tranquille
[Applaudissements]
je me trompe pas quand je rentre du
millionième la fois que vous avez
répondu à 523 députés ou 500 bahts nage
mais france 3 ils sont 40 il y en a un
qui joue à caen dick roche le tout se
décide à le troisième il écope
les impôts tu es en train de dormir trop
pâtir des lois importantes qui sont
votées vous êtes 40 députés à une heure
du matin pour voter les lois vous n'êtes
même pas foutu d'aller dans votre
assemblée dans vos pelures effet la
réponse du mal et c'est mon événement si
moi je dis je dors je pose mon camion je
dors le chauffeur de bus il est fatigué
il s'arrête il fait des allées on peut
encore avoir la réponse de moguai mais
faut qu'il respecte ne connais mon
combat il voudrait que je réponds de
mode ou pas à moi je veux bien qu'on me
réponde moment plus en plus je vous
adore j'ai suivi sur twitter vous avez
jamais
[Applaudissements]
et
j'avais l'air avec tous les gens qui
vous prenez des vents alors baissé by
antho sa politique alors il faudrait que
vous le suis bien sûr qu'hier et je vais
vous suivre sur twitter
non mais tu me dis
non mexique je vais juste voilà juste
pour appeler moi je suis belliraj est un
boulot je me suis parfaitement matin le
métro conduit rennes probablement parce
tu prends h fondu la 3 ou l'a13 non
l'intérieur de jeu donc tu vois on est
beaucoup déjà à faire de la politique de
façon bénévole avoir un job à côté ça
c'est la première chose ensuite le
président est dans quoi vous dans
l'aéronautique thunder muclair nucléaire
le président il n'a pas insulté les
français au contraire on passe notre
temps à dire qu'on veut que le travail
paie plus que le travail c'est quelque
chose d'important pour nous alors je
comprends que tu es plus longtemps comme
une maladresse mais c'était pas une
insulte mais ma mère vraiment non il ya
des choses factuelles et on dit boel
nous on veut permettre aux gens de ja de
trouver un travail aujourd'hui un taux
de chômage qui à 7,6 et quand même
historiquement bas d'autant plus après
la crise qu'on vient de traverser et
donc on continue à investir dans la
formation continue à investir dans les
dispositifs d'insertion unis mais ont
ensuite demain les gens et vous vous
dites mon chef dans votre discours monde
globalis pas les politiques enseignante
tout litige
même là vous aurez d'infiniti est ce que
vous êtes en train de dire je vous êtes
en train de dire et si on veut que les
français travaillent plus les français
ils veulent pas travailler plus ils
veulent qu'on les paye course et dont il
veut un peu chers élus cités ils veulent
que vous aviez tout arrêter
pas dit qu'il voulait pas voir ses
enfants de saint louis dimanche la
caissière à l'ap a dit qu'elle voulait
aller travailler le dimanche ils veulent
avoir une vie convenable et
géraldine maillet est monté le contre
exemple tu veux travailler mais moi je
travaille moi je m'en fous je travaille
j'ai nommé s'était donc toi tu vas bien
travailler plus pour gagner plus
d'argent mais bah oui mais n'y a pas de
mal à ça mais j'ai dit qu'il y avait un
mal étudie les français veulent pas
travailler plus toi tu généraliste mais
faire l avenir que macro généralistes
pourquoi tu as tu globalise ya aussi des
français qui mènent très français qui
bossent comme des chiens et à la villa
du mois que 10 1280 mais je le vois rien
qui à côté car rien foutu de sa journée
qui fera rien de sa journée depuis dix
ans lui il va avoir des chèques emploi
service lui ward échec pour le gaz lui
ça ne les a jamais rien foutu pour la
france le raid
et me lisant les plus forts
c'est vous dire
vous aidez toujours les mauvaises
personnes les gens nés gilet jaune
c'était quoi c'était des gens qui
voulaient juste aller travailler j'ai
mis le plein de ma citroën c5 90 bas sur
une citroën 90 euros vous allez vous
arrêter quand vous augmentez les sont
toutes
montées tout près le gouvernement
commencer vous venez dire en français y
pas le gouver les français sont des
feignants
vertes ont démarré hier
[Applaudissements]
matin au jardin oui mais parce que mes
trois dames et pourtant tu devrais de
sorte que toi tu te lèves tôt et tu
rentres chez toi et vert je les vois les
gens tu seras français que quelqu'un y
en a qui prend le métro qui fait une
heure et demie transport à l'aller 1h30
transport au retour 3 heures pour
rentrer chez lui il va tout payer ses
factures ses dettes à la fin il à son
président qui les vit droit dans les
yeux si tu veut du boulot traces la rue
et les français s'est défini travail
mode mode vadim haut débit qui s'est
toujours pas sur twitter un brouillard
de
fait mais bien mode typiquement
l'adorent mode ça il est tout
justement les gens qui bossent comme toi
on envie qu'il gagne davantage comme moi
je ne souhaiterais pas on a travaillé
sur les heures sup ou avait déjà dit sur
la prime d'activité les impôts on les a
b c la taxe d'habitation on l'a su c'est
vrai enfin bref voilà et donc ça aurait
c'est normal que les personnes qui
soient plus précaires il ya aussi des
gens tous les gens au chômage ne sont
pas des gens qui décident d'être au
chômage pas dit ça j'ai parlé 2 x 15 ans
que j'ai c'est qu'on est donc jamais dit
quoi ont besoin il faut continuer à les
aider qu'on aide aussi les personnes qui
sont le plus dans la précarité
absolument aller dialogue
démagogie on n'a pas travaillé plus et
qu'on gagne tous plus d'argent et puis
ce n'est pas plus beau plus fort inquiet
pas de souci et pippa de chômage puis
peuvent bien ça marche pas comme ça
répond la vérité c'est que on est cent
trente septième pays sur 138 voilà en
termes de travail donc non on travaille
pas beaucoup à dire et on se rend compte
et quand sarkozy avait dansé travailler
plus pour gagner plus on s'est rendu
compte que ça n'a pas été un énorme
carton et jean préféré s'arrêter à 17h
et gagner un petit peu moins vrai il y
en a six voiliers plus pour les heures
sup j'en faisais partie
d'un jury télé j'en ai pas travailler
jusqu'à belge aujourd'hui après le
corrige quelques vides 17% de croissance
tous les restaurants david checa tout
évident partout donc des pâtes dit dit
la vérité ou si vraiment c'est pas vrai
on est happé feignants non c'est pas des
cours
monsieur
mais c'est aussi un mouton à des
hôpitaux des écoles on a toujours eu et
donc on est un pays très pauvre et moins
qu'à côté raymond dit la vérité tu te
trompe de combat en regard des gens en
france assister au combat aujourd'hui
j'ai le temps de me dire ça fait 15 ans
qu'ils foutent rien ça fait 15 ans qu'on
les aide ils n'ont pas versé un euro
d'impôt cela arrange la forge mais c'est
pas le sujet la part des gens qui sont
au chômage ils décident pas des sauces
tomate c'est pas de leur faute et la
plupart du temps c'est les patrons qui
sont trop taxés qui ferme les bois on se
fait et tu le sais est un tâche est un
chef d'entreprise on se fait piller les
lémuriens ou de partout on sait pied les
marchés à cause du à cause de la charge
du travail tels moi tu sais ce que ça
coûte les charges sociales mais alors
est ce que ça coûte tu sais ce que ça
coûte le lot numéro 1
française et 13e trous du personnel
tu vas suivi la sq a dit emmanuel macron
[Applaudissements]
par contre vous l'accès des bas si vous
pouviez suivre également guillaume
genton palm avait dit moi parce qu'il
vous aimez beaucoup compté mais ok
d'accord vous aime beaucoup liée au
genre ton voile à herrère on va faire un
tour à pau aux états unis mais je veux
ressembler à une grosse boîte il a
consenti à lyon il est bien lui-même des
profits qui
désirent vraiment la seule existence dit
la suède l'angleterre le guatemala je
m'en bats les c
les français c'est les gens qui voient
dans le métro le matin mais c'est le
débat avait rien à faire l'économie a
move raymond bcd par nos maux les etats
unis c'est pas un exemple qu'on voit des
tirs d'obus caisse moi je trouve pas je
trouve pas que l'état dise ce soit un
exemple aux requêtes portant de chômage
ces travailleurs et les travailleuses
états unis à miami los angeles alors ma
mère ma mère m'en vois la taxe
d'habitation existe toujours fo va pas
la payer aujourd'hui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça décoiffe appelé du foyer nan on
écoute moi s'il te plaît que la taxe
d'habitation a été pour le moment
supprimé pour 80% des français et en
2023 elle le sera pour cent pour cent
des parents est ton papa way dont
le père a pu la taxe d'habitation pour
l'instant il fait partie pendant un an
et demi je connais pas ces ressources
fiscales
je suis tombé mais s'il est dans les
derniers ça veut dire que globalement
les cd dvd un petit peu
tout va bien et dont il travaille
travaille voile et travaille encore donc
voilà bannière ci en tout cas moi ma
mère me dit elle est sympa cette mode
2008 je vais la suivre sur twitter
alors oui à 32% êtes vous d'accord avec
les propos d'emmanuel vacon non à 67%
voyez